mairal l'arrière saison et beaucoup
mieux que le mois de juillet le mois
d'août partir en vacances en septembre
un voeu pieux pour la majorité des
français obligés de se caler sur les
vacances scolaires les années 60 la
grande migration estivale était pointé
du doigt les français jean heureux sont
chaque année plus nombreux à partir en
vacances
l'ennui c'est qu'il met un entêtement
certains à le faire en même temps
en moins de deux mois la moitié des
français fut en vacances c'est à dire
parfaitement passé et pourtant les
vacances de septembre tout le monde y
pense mais seuls certains en profitent
les plus jeunes et surtout les plus
vieux c'est à dire moi d'autres élèves
de nabeul la chaleur enfin traitement ne
prenons pas le tourisme de septembre va
commencer à se développer dans les
années 70 timidement mais sûrement comme
le note ce transporteur maritime qui
relie le continent et la corse en 1978
au début du mois de septembre est tout
bonnement sensationnel dans les dix
premiers jours nous enregistrons à
l'arrivée ajaccio 100 ans
quatre mille trois cents passagers de
plus que l'an dernier en pourcentage
cela fait cinquante sept pour cent dans
les années 80 les retraités en goguette
devienne le coeur de cible des
professionnels du tourisme
ils sont actifs et toujours plus
nombreux et ils amusent les journalistes
c'est une espèce qui fleurit en
septembre à mes yeux ronds unis avec un
rebord où un cordon c'est la grande
saison du bob et ceux qui ont oublié
leur s'arrange pour trouver une parade
les retraités sont de retour avec thor
formule de vacances bien à eux
le groupe et ils sont adorés des
professionnels du tourisme en
comparaison des familles de juillet et
d'août les retraités de septembre de
belles qualités
ils dépensent plus de ce sont des gens
qui n'ont pas peur du lendemain
donc la retraite c'est leur problème des
pensions budget le nez pour le senior
seul ou en groupe est devenu un moteur
économique essentiel de l'arrière saison
touristique en 2014
près d'un tiers des nuitées de touristes
français ont été réalisés par des
personnes de plus de soixante deux ans
[Musique]